this is you know a home away from home
for every las vegan and so
it breaks my heart
heartbreaking indeed a las vegas staple
has burned down we thank you for joining
us here at noon i'm john langler and we
start with a story we've been following
since good day early this morning the
mount charleston lodge is gone an early
morning fire destroyed the old
restaurant the lodge up there decades of
memories are now gone we have team
coverage of what took place up on the
mountain nate tanaban is going to talk
about how some of this little bit of
rain might be helping the situation up
there but we start with hector mejia on
mount charleston with the latest hector
yeah well luckily right now no reports
of injuries or of anyone missing but
firefighters as you can see still on the
scene and this is what's left of the
mount charleston lodge some tough news
to see tough news to swallow when you
look at what's left pretty much a shell
of a building out there in the distance
some small fires underneath some of the
rubble still right now creating some
light smoke out there and right now the
roof is the main concern for the
firefighters out here because it
collapsed a couple of times and here's
the latest in terms of where this
started firefighters now believe the
fire may have started in or near the
dining room area we're told the first
911 around 4 45 a.m we have cell phone
video that shows the intense hot flames
all around the lodge earlier management
reports that all employees had left
around nine last night and once it's
safe to go inside they'll conduct the
primary search clark county fire tells
us that this was an old building with
additions made to it throughout the
decades so they had some challenges
reaching some of the flames hiding
underneath some of the rubble there
we're also told this could have been so
much worse
cabins are nearby pretty close to the
lodge multiple fire departments rushed
in and kept the fire from spreading to
anything else
it's one pine tree for another pine tree
and then another you know pretty soon we
could have potentially had
a large forest fire
everybody loves the lodge it's such a
vegas
tradition that i mean it's really
heartbreaking
gutted
nauseous
i grew up coming into you know the
spring mountains you know mount
charleston was a playground for me
growing up i got married right up here
at cathedral rock
we received a written statement from
marketing director christina ellis who
said in part quote the surrounding area
and the cabins were both left untouched
we'd like to thank all the first
responders who assisted and she also
said the lodge was a beloved landmark
and we plan on rebuilding and recreating
the atmosphere and charm that so many
were able to enjoy and obviously a tough
loss for everyone out there even first
responders shared with us some of the
memories that they made inside the lodge
we've seen some changes in terms of the
weather it was sunny when we got here it
rained and now it's back sunny again